hello and a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking germany the
show where we do just that my guest
today is the acclaimed german writer
matthias politiki and here he is in
person thank you matthias for coming all
the way to berlin today to be with us
here on talking germany thank you for
dividing me great stuff now
matthias politiki is a globetrotting
author of essays poems and novels
including his latest samakant samakant
which is i suppose a dark exploration of
the clash of cultures he's also a bit of
a controversialist and he's got involved
in some of the big public debates here
in germany in recent years and best of
all he's very entertaining so
plenty to look forward to yeah
you're smiling a little bit about the
introduction
i would like to welcome you here today
as a representative of german literature
yeah because
german literature is deep boring and
plotless
i know that yeah it's your quote yeah
yeah
that's what happened to me when when i
had my first reading in london um
my counterpart
opened to the public we know german
literature and i thought oh wow
yes that's what the british think
of us
and then she said well
but there is something like matthias
politiki as well and so i was happy to
have her at my side
but um yeah i learned a lot about how
english look towards
the germans
those days and especially to german
literature and sometimes they are right
sometimes well i mean you yourself you
once started a campaign for something
that you called
new german readability yes what was that
all about
well
maybe it was a kind of a english idea of
it it has to be fun to read it it
doesn't only it shouldn't only be
work reading a book so after having
accomplished and done you could relieve
and say it was a great book i've read it
and this is maybe
the type of literature i thought was a
bit outdated yeah in our days
i don't like all these light stuff but i
think you if you don't like the light
stuff
well
either
i think good literature is always both
it has to have a deep
solemn ground but
to to well to
be a pleasure
being read it's interesting because the
the backdrop to what you're saying is
the fact that here in germany and more
than in any other country i know there's
a big divide between serious culture
and entertainment it's a very big divide
where does that come from
i don't know i'm not old enough to know
but i've grown up with that it's called
e literature for ants serious that's
where you furrow your brow yeah
entertainment
sometimes and i proclaimed in another
essay we need eu
literature
which is of course european as well
which is the second aspect of my idea of
literature this cosmopolitan
attempt
but
this is where i still stand now at eu
that's the clue to the heart of a reader
okay but tell me sort of what shape is
german literature in at the moment
because i what happens with me very
often is that i'll go to the us or i'll
go to the uk or wherever and i'll say to
people what should i be reading what's
interesting and people will say if
you've got a piece of paper and a pen
and we'll make a list
yeah and they'll tell me about all
things i'll go out and buy the books and
i'll read them when i say to people here
in germany i've got friends outside
germany who are interested or would be i
could be interested in new german
literature what can you recommend
they sort of go hmm
tough question
well at least i i don't well i could
start recommending
topic now and but just think about jen
spatu who is uh my age of our age
somewhere in between and um he's an east
german writer yeah a brilliant writer he
studied philosophy and in the old well
ddr of course and
lived in moscow oh no petersburg i think
for a while and
well she
he writes brilliant novels for example
very funny
but always with this
serious um
interior
okay
that's interesting i'm very very
grateful for that we had here on the
show we had aegon ruger who was uh
also who came from the east grew up in
the east and wrote about very very a
brilliant book about the eastern and the
guy you're recommending tell me his name
again and tell me for the viewers as
well
and especially
that's one of his famous uh books okay
bestseller okay yeah
getting more enthusiastic about new
german literature
matthias
writers are also readers of course and
and you've been quoted as saying if i
could only read again like i did when i
was a child yeah just describe for me
the passion and the energy you had as a
young boy for
reading well the books
in those days opened a new world to me
for call my or
julian or whomever you
just name them
they
i was traveling the world just sitting
in my
little room meanwhile and i couldn't
stop reading
so my parents had to sometimes to force
me to go outside and
that was
well i was i felt
happy it's not the gluckly he's a bit
more i think than happy i was
blissful i didn't
i i
didn't need to do anything else
and
my mother was same type once i remember
when i was a very little child i
couldn't read it in
those days
but she
read every
day was lying on the sofa reading
reading reading and once she forgot to
cook
lunch and i went down
and i looked at her and thought to
myself
wow that must be fascinating she must be
hungry like i am but and i didn't dare
to interrupt i still remember that so
that is really interesting
my own mother it was very interesting
because it would get a sort of a real
working-class household and she would do
whatever needed to be done until sort of
10 or 11 o'clock in the evening and then
she would go upstairs in one of these
you know english sort of upstairs
downstairs houses and she would and she
would say i'm going upstairs to read now
yeah and it sounded like the most
important moment of the day for her yeah
but nowadays of course it's part of the
work to read what others have written to
read for well for research for for a
novel and so on it's a completely
different way of reading that's why i
think i wrote this sentence okay
i understood i understand that you
actually began writing to try and win a
girl's heart
that's true
and i i didn't win it
i couldn't i couldn't i couldn't nobody
could but
as we all start no not all but few of us
started and then
well it was a good time even though the
girl stayed apart or it was a men's club
16 year old man in the woods outside of
munich
reading poems to each other it sounds
like like a bad
a b movie but that is my youth and
i started to discuss poems and that it
was great of course some times somebody
had grabbed a bottle of wine from his
father and we sat there
half night long and
looked at the sky and discussed about
poems wonderful lovely memories
talking of girls let's talk about women
because one of you your breakthrough
novel we just heard about it was called
viber roman woman's novel it hasn't
really it hasn't been translated it was
a real bestseller it was about a guy
called gregor
schneider yeah fascinating name he's an
i think it's fair to say an every man
somebody who sort of represents his own
generation and there's a there's a lot
of you in it yeah so i'd like to ask you
you're really joking
are you a typical product of your
generation
oh yes i am
um uh as we call it the 78ers
uh
without the 6866
these are the
more
representative maybe uh
for
if you look from from other countries
towards germany the 1680s were more
relevant maybe that's
that's part of the problem already
um
we
had a very
long but
golden youth
nothing really had to be done the job
was already done by the elder
um so um we had a lot of time to
well to
to read poetry
to
and i think in the long run
that was necessary to produce a new type
of literature
we write completely different books than
the
elder generations
other topics other style other sound
other written
and still we lack
the
v
ornament of our generation or the
single
movement as in paris 68 or berlin and
frankfurt
we don't have that and maybe that is
part of the definition already
okay that's interesting uh you're
more recently you've you you wrote and
you you published a novel which was
called the next world novella we've got
it we've got it here and it's got a very
very good english translation it's a
very intriguing book
it's about a man who is an unremarkable
man who has a remarkable wife what does
that tell us about men and women
if you're lucky
you could be this man
well um i hope it
it's just
a novel it doesn't tell anything about
you or my uh
uh life because it all ends not only uh
it begins with the death of his wife but
it uh it's getting worse and worse
turning the pages so um
let's keep it a literary character okay
and uh well i i've had a lot of readings
and a lot of readers write to me that
they stopped
talk to each other
being married means in the long run
to
not to stop talking
i think that's the the main
thing you do when you are married or
there are some more interesting or more
fascinating aspects of being married but
talking to each other or
in the long run stopping to talk
tells a lot about the relation
and this is what readers write to me
because that's
of course the tragedy of this couple as
well
as we discovered in that reported that
the novel took you 25 years to write why
did it take that long
i couldn't i couldn't do it
i started again and again
sometimes
i was lucky till page number
100 yeah
some other attempts ended earlier
um but um
1987 i was an experimental author as we
call it
an author who
plays with words and the colors of the
vowels
was uh the topic of this first novel in
1987 and you can picture me
worrying about the
well the sounds and the the colors of
the vowels this is not really the
the plot that uh what came out yeah it's
not a book that is
really
a
kind of a thriller that i i wanted to
write
and i discovered that it's much easier
to to write in an experimental way to
present all the or what you can do with
language than
just to
concentrate
on the plot and serve the reader i think
we are kind of
like
not servants but we are without readers
we are nothing
it's not the author who writes only
for himself or for other authors no we
write for readers so we have to
to concentrate okay you write for
readers it's the book the book has been
described by one critic as politiki's
vision of the end of the west that
sounds very
dramatic and very pessimistic
is it true yeah you you know how critics
write
of course they want to grab the reader
as well
as i want with the book no it's a
critical moment in
western
history and
yeah
but still there's kauffner
the main character trying to fulfill the
mission and
on the very last page we don't know if
he was able to or not i don't want to
really be very cautious you don't want
to reveal too much it's still open it's
still open
symbolism is very important as we saw in
the report you see you've got russian
propaganda coming from the mosque you've
got you've got the moiseen calling the
faithful to prayer from a hamburg church
tower it's about the twin towers being
destroyed which was a symbolic act as as
much as anything else why is that
symbolism so important
um to us as being
europeans and
after enlightenment of we tend to
discuss everything with our well
intellectual way of interpreting
the facts and the others but traveling
outside this cosmos of enlightenment
you soon get to know that other
mentalities
not only concentrate on intellectualism
they
what happened
when well trade center was attacked i
was shocked that it's a criminal act
it's terrorism but to
lots of people we saw them dancing in
the street by our tv
it was a symbolic uh
action uh in the holy war
to me that's
still a crime
but
picture them being
being uh well being
not being
uh
in in
being part of a conflict that is
dominated by the west if you talk about
the gaza
gaza people or
afghanistan or whomever
and that's the last idea they have to
attack
the west via symbolic acts to at least
have symbolic victories
it's still a crime but
it could happen to a declining
western
rest of
europe as well if no other means
is there to grab if you're helpless
your protagonist alexander kaufman how
much of you did a lot of research
research is very very important to you
one when you were there in uzbekistan we
saw you in the report what did you learn
about uzbekistan what did you learn
about the people
oh there are hundreds of peoples living
there in one
country
i learned that it's not only
let's say central asians no
it's tajik it's uzbek it's kyrgyz it's
russians it's it's uh from iran from
from everywhere it's a melting pot and
we could picture them as being
multiculty
part of the new global world but
the truth is the very opposite
they are just living
one aside the other
there's a village of the turks the next
villages touching in the big cities of
course
but they the problems start already
and it made me nervous as i was raised
with multicultural ideas
and i still stick to them but i had to
learn it's not that easy
there is of course a really big debate
here in germany about multiculturalism
about you know whether to what extent
multi the multicultural society is
working in germany or is not working
here we'll talk about that in just a
second
i know this is something that you've
given quite a lot of thought about to
religion culture and the role it plays
and i want and i just wonder what you
can tell me about how important or not
the church is these days in germany
well i just think think of our history
the division
between the north and the south the
catholic south and the protestant north
so you get germany in a nutshell it's
not east and west as we always think no
it's the north and the south it's a very
very important important point you're
making if you want to understand germany
you need to understand that north south
yeah i'm a southerner i was raised in
munich and i
i fell in love with a woman living in
hamburg so i changed places but that was
more than changing the places it's it's
a complete new
it's the jacket and and the coat and the
house and everything and the sound of
the city is different uh protestantism
is
something else even though i'm a
protestant uh in from munich but that's
another story so um
when i was in research for next world
novella i needed a church in berlin who
rang the bells
every hour or i would have preferred
every
quarter of an hour
and it took me weeks and months of
research
because they don't ring the bells any
longer because all and this is typical
for the role of religion in in our
christian society that nobody who lived
there wanted
the church to ring the bells it was just
noise to them but can you picture a
vibrant religion
called
catholicism or protestantism without
ringing the bells every now and then
it's interesting when you use the word
their vibrant religion you talk about
people the bell's no longer ringing
people we've just heard from the
reporter leaving the churches here in
germany in droves it's often said uh do
you i got the feeling from samar khan
sama khan in a way that you actually
possibly envy people
who have real religious conviction
in a certain way i do
as i was raised with nietzsche
who as you know
said god is dead and so on and so on and
so on and
it's not only
that i
keep that sentence in mind but
it
from the mind it came to
a bit lower to my heart and to all my
bones and it now it's in my bones that i
there's no god left for us any longer
and when i go abroad and and have
discussions with imams starting in the
in the the near east but with wow with
african voodoo priests and so on they
are so strong in their way of
interpreting the world and i'm always
the
enlightened tolerant
nice guy from the western world
understanding everything and everybody
and saying fine what you're doing and
sometimes i come home and
say wow they don't think fine what
you're doing no no it's fine that we do
what we do and you should do that as
well that's something else
it's interesting when you're talking
about those those kind of fault lines
between cultures and religions there was
samuel huntington several years ago now
wrote a book about the clash of
civilizations and lots of liberals
pounced on him and said that that
doesn't describe the world in which we
live but i i think to an extent what
we're seeing is that cultures are doing
that there's a sort of a confluence of
cultures and cultures learning from each
other and overlapping but at the same
time there is a clash of cultures is
there not
that's what you describe in your book in
some accounts
the intellectuals i think they mingle
and they form a new global society which
i i would love to uh well to be the
structure for the whole world but it's
not if you look uh some levels uh
more close to
where the ground where our feet are not
only where
you
you have to accept that
all over
in the world there is a well a
redefinition of
of
regional uh cultures who don't want to
belong to this global
culture of the whole world it started in
europe with with yugoslavia and all that
we have
russia and ukraine nowadays and this
will not be the last chapter of the
story
i hate that
but on the other side i have to
understand
that people don't want to live in
abstract
visions of
even if it's a european uh community
which i really favor
i'm
really a european by heart but i come
across a lot of people who
prefer to say
spanish
this and even in germany they don't want
to stay german maybe this is a problem
but a variant you once said you once
said i like being german yeah what
specifically do you like about being
german
oh i think we learned our lesson well
i mean the historical lesson
i can see it wherever i come across
representatives of my generation we're
open-minded we
don't
think that we have nothing to do with
the black sides of our history but
and we keep that in mind but on the
other hand we found back to a more a
lighter way of being german we we don't
go to the seller if we are in need of
laughing
of course some days we say okay tomorrow
we laugh about the joke but still we
stay on ground floor
so this is a difference sometimes
especially in england people wonder oh
you're german and there's so many like
me i think
this is
what we are nowadays germans
and wherever i come across them of
course we hide from each other in the
first
step but then it if we come at ease it's
always good to because they
they are some others are more stubborn
in their way
well matthias politiki i mean call me a
snob if you want uh
i i've never been on a cruise liner and
i might never go on one i'm not sure
give me good reasons to do so
the sea the scene that's the only chance
that you can live
on in or from under the sea if you
in the very
close to the bottom
for
a longer period and of course you just
if you think about all the destinations
it's
it's
in the long end it's it's always too
short that's not the reason to go on a
cruise
cruise ship but
living that close to the sea
for several weeks that makes you look
differently towards the waves
the kind of blue greenish
the atmosphere the sky changes from
from from island to island and the
approach to the islands is great as well
you cannot travel this by a bus
no you have to you have to have a ship
you're beginning to win me over you're
beginning to convince me yeah you were
on you were on board the ms europa for
um 184
days yeah which is halfway how did that
come about
well it like all big stories
you know from from american novels they
start with a telephone call
so um that happened to me as well and so
all from a sudden i was in a in a
discussion with hubbard lloyd
who had the idea of
installing
the first and the last
writer in residence because it wasn't
easy in the long run for both sides to
survive
because writers are well there's not a
typical
person who goes on a cruise
tour
still i enjoyed it and uh but let's just
have a look at one or two photos yeah of
you on the on the vessel as it were yeah
and tell me what we're seeing tell me
what's going on
nothing
nothing much yeah i was writing every
day i've had a blog on this tour which
was the basis based off my then
of my novel uh yeah we were going to an
island again in my cabin
working yeah i was working pretty good
reading together with uh with john
manhattan who had a little jazz on it
preparing for dinner time
looking very smart indeed
sometimes even writers have to wear
smokings so well i enjoyed even the
smoking i didn't i didn't have a smoking
before so
yeah very good you did look very very
smart dude
from what you're saying reading between
the lines or listening very closely to
what you're saying i have the sense that
although you enjoyed looking away from
the boat out to sea
what was going on behind you was a
little bit alienating to use a little to
use a big word you know
yeah there were great guys on board no
question about that but these funny
types that you
picture were there as well
and if they were only aliens fine but
some of
them had problems with me writing about
the ship and the tour
as a writer does with fantasy and uh
describing was
not going on on the ship they thought i
was a journalist and and they read the
blog as well and they complained the
other day and said what are you doing
man we are not feeding animals with the
diamonds of of our ladies after dinner
to prepare the next uh
but no
what should people think if they read
that and they did read the blog that was
for sure and i said fine it's it's a
novel
keep cool but they had no clue what i
meant so
i got big problems with part of the crew
there was one captain who
well
but the other was
becoming my friend
so those types exist on on those boats
when he was the captain i had great
times as well okay so i have an
ambivalent uh
memory but
it was worth going there
and
would you say no if somebody i'm waiting
if you don't call you're still waiting
we're running out of time a wee little
bit and you've got you've brought along
we like to ask our guests to bring along
a cherished possession yeah let me just
have a look let's have a look at this
yeah yeah okay it's a table marker it's
a table it's not from the boat no no
it's from moshi which is a little town
in africa and tanzania where just coming
from and as you see here it's uh close
to the kilimanjaro oh yeah yeah and
i was spent four days in this hotel as i
wanted to run the kilimanjaro marathon
as what i did and saying goodbye to
everybody
i
i grabbed it and said i'd love to have
it and it took me one hour to convince
them and they found the manager and the
manager came appeared an indian guy and
said you want that it's nothing it's not
a real souvenir whether it's more than a
souvenir it's authentic it's it's a
symbol of of the hotel and of the whole
trip the kilimanjaro marathon please and
he gave it to me as a present as i
promised to him i'll come back and then
climb it next time now i ran it and next
time oh and i drank it as well that's
kilimanjaro beer as well
that's good there's good that you
mentioned beer because i was going to
move on slowly but surely to our talking
germany quiz at the end of the show
ah i hear the music you've written a
book it's here it's only published in
german about german and english beer
yeah yeah i've got to ask you being
english which is better german or
english beer
sorry to say bavarian bavarian beer good
answer
that is your lot with the entertaining
matthias politiki if you've enjoyed his
company as much as i have then do come
back next week until then bye bye
you